mais d'abord ces images vous allez les
découvrir des dizaines de personnes
faisant la queue à l'extérieur de la
salle du jeu de paume à blois
pour peu on se croirait de retour à la
vie d'avant en réalité un ticket pour
celle d'après 3 vaccinodromes comme
celui ci ont donc ouvert chez nous les
deux autres sont à saint-avertin et
saint cyr sur loire
chacun capables de vacciner 500 à 1000
personnes par jour quand il fallait une
semaine paul boyer et lucas chopin était
présent pour ce nouveau coup
d'accélérateur des centaines de
personnes patientent avant de recevoir
leur première dose une fois enregistrés
on s'occupe comme on peut pour passer le
temps au rythme d'une vaccination par
minute le nouveau vaccinodromes deux
blocs ont bien passé la vitesse
supérieure avec un objectif de 200
vaccinations par jour
il suffit de prendre un rendez vous sur
dr libre il reste encore des créneaux
disponibles pour jeudi et vendredi de la
semaine prochaine donc vous voyez à des
dates qui sont des dates raisonnable en
tout cas assez proches c'est plus de 50
personnes qui sont mobilisées par
demi-journée 50 personnes le matin
cinquante personnes l'après-midi de
façon à ce que l'on puisse réaliser ses
900 vaccinations par jour
à notre tour nous avons essayé de
réserver un créneau sur d'octo libre
manque de chance plus aucune place
disponible
le site précise néanmoins que des
créneaux seront mises en ligne dans les
prochains jours
pour être éligibles à la vaccination il
faut avoir plus de 70 ans ou avoir entre
50 et 70 ans avec comorbidités une fois
la dose reçue c'est le soulagement du
côté des patients je viens de faire
vacciner pour la première fois première
injection je me suis décidée au dernier
moment en passant par dr libre puis je
pouvais m'inscrire et de là je suis
parti je pense que ces citoyens comme
acte quoi il faut le faire parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'autre solution pour
l'instant on andré loire ces deux
nouveaux vaccinodromes qui voit le jour
là un saint-avertin l'autre à
saint-cyr-sur-loire de sites
spécialement choisis pour faciliter
l'accès aux patients ici
on a une grande salle avec un grand
parking des voies de communication et un
passage de bus alors forcément quand on
arrive à relier tout ça ça fait un site
tout à fait tout à fait intéressant pour
pouvoir monter ce type d'opération
aujourd'hui presque un demi million
d'injection ont été réalisés en centre
val de loire
malgré cela les taux d'incidence demeure
toujours très élevé il est de 365 pour
cent mille habitants en indre et loire
le loir et cher n'est pas très loin avec
48 patients en réanimation en indre et
loire et 18 patients en loir et cher